the one that was my most memorable
probably one of the first experiments
was was a little bit later in life was
with starting zoos in my when I was I
don't know 13 14 and I was this was for
science fair project and I was a total
science partner growing up and did
science first every year and loved it
and I I was researching this this drug
called melatonin and it was kind of
interested in its properties in terms of
affecting the circadian rhythms and
pineal gland of these unicellular
organisms called raw defers so raw
defers are basically these like black
blobs the globe they're growing swamps
and so I decided to take this room off
of our kitchen and turn it into my lab
not to everyone's great pleasure in my
house and had these petri dishes set up
with different raw defers and I would
sort of put different amounts of
melatonin and different amounts of
different chemicals and so we created
this little kind of lab set up with a
microscope and that was one of the first
signs were projects turning the kitchen
into a microbiology lab I always don't
want to be in science I think from an
early age from Hawaii 13 14 from from
just kind of fooling around in the
backyard and you know causing things to
blow up or to cut catch on fire to look
at something under a microscope or look
at something like a magnifying glass
just kind of see watching looking at
ants I mean that was highly pleasurable
you know lifting up this rock that we
had and there was always just a ton of
ants and seeing how they would move
around and kind of build a little
community down there it always
fascinated me I loved looking at
pictures of science and it was as much
the kind of aesthetics of science that
appealed to me as anything else I've
always been fascinated by how science
looks the architecture and design of
science as much as the more
philosophical ideas in science in fact
it was an image of a protein
was done to an x-ray crystallography so
basically looking at the structure of a
protein of this particular protein
that's responsible for how our cells
adhere to one another and it turned out
that this molecule looks like a zipper
zipper in between ourselves sort of a
molecular zipper and it was seeing an
image an x-ray crystallography image of
that protein complex that got me on a
path for a few years of doing
biochemical research and cancer research
it was an image it was sort of the
architecture of this protein that was
just so compelling and overwhelmingly
satisfying and kind of a visceral for a
romantic way an aesthetic way that led
me to then try to understand it further
in in a more you know deeply biochemical
way so it's always been as much the
language and aesthetics and culture of
science as it has been the actual
scientific ideas themselves that have
excited me
you